well good afternoon everyone my name is
Tony elizabeth's I'm the director of
strategic initiatives and the Yale
project and climate change here at the
school of Forestry and environmental
studies I'd first like to take a moment
to welcome the Leadership Council of the
school and the many alumni who have
returned for alumni weekend it's really
great to have you all back I'd also like
to thank the Yale office of
sustainability for their support of
today's lecture and their everyday
efforts to make sustainability a reality
right here right now at Yale and here in
New Haven and thank you all of course
for coming today to the second of our
new visions of a sustainable world
lecture series today we're delighted to
welcome Alex Stephan as our second
speaker in this series now by way of
background this project emerged from a
recent conference the school convened in
Aspen Colorado of leading natural and
social scientists philosophers religious
scholars practitioners and
philanthropists that worked hard to
identify the shift in underlying values
and worldviews required to support a
transition to sustainable world now
among its many conclusions the group
recognized that there is currently a
critical need for inspiring yet
practical visions of a sustainable world
and roadmaps to get us there for decades
society has had to react to a seemingly
endless series of environmental crises
oil spills air and water pollution
toxics deforestation endangered species
and now global climate change but in
responding to these many threats the
environmental community has
unfortunately often been better at
articulating what it is against then
articulating what it's for thus
Environmental Research and Action has
often not been strategic in pursuit of a
visionary goal and set of ideals to
quote the sociologist amitai etzioni
most people are not nor do they seek to
become policy wonks or technocrats most
yearn for an overarching picture of what
we are trying to achieve one that
provides a framework for placing
specific ideas assessing past
accomplishments and planning for the
future
we seek a vision that inspires compels
and gives meaning to our endeavors and
sacrifices to life itself it is now
clear that the environmental crisis is
global in scale elongated in time and
interwoven with global trends far beyond
the scope of conventional
environmentalism the environment can no
longer be separated from issues like the
current economic crisis capital flows
and globalization advances in science
technology and medicine revolutions in
communications in computing mass
urbanisation and migrations and changing
lifestyles and levels of affluence
around the world it's growing clear that
the world must make the transition to a
sustainable prosperous and healthy
planetary society yet it is still very
unclear to most of us what the
sustainable future might look like or
how to create it in fact confronted with
the many problems of the world it's very
easy to become fatalistic or worse
cynical about the future yet to quote
Henry Ford those who think they can and
those who think they can't are both
right in this context this lecture
series hopes to catalyze concrete
visions of the economies political
systems environments values and
lifestyles of a saint of the sustainable
world that does in fact lie within our
reach today we're delighted to welcome
Alex Stefan founder of world-changing a
solutions based online magazine and
community devoted to envisioning a
bright green future and finding sharing
and tracking the emerging ideas tools
and breakthroughs that are bringing it
into reality today world-changing was
the hundred and thirty-fifth most cited
blog in the world in july two thousand
eight wow Nielsen rated at the second
leading sustainability site in the world
after treehugger.com I'm sure you all
are avid tree hugger what readers while
time magazine named it one of the
world's top 15 environmental websites
alex is also the editor of the
award-winning book world changing a
user's guide for the 21st century which
has received rave reviews from across
the environment community including from
former Vice President Al
Gor who said this book not only shows
what is already possible but also helps
all of us imagine what might be in our
own homes in our communities and for the
planet as a whole taken together these
solutions present a picture of a future
that is not dark or catastrophic but one
that is full of hope and within our
grasp and with that please join me in
welcoming Alex stuff into Yale hi can
you all hear me this thing on so yes I'm
Alex Stefan I run world-changing we are
a tiny little nonprofit that has a
website that you just heard about we
also put out newsletters we do events we
have a PDF magazine that we published
twice a year all these things are are
free we do take donations and I'm
obliged to say that as the executive
director of a non-profit we also have an
auction up right now that you might be
interested in but what I'm here to talk
to you about today is really much more
the deeper work that we do which is
about trying to envision solutions to
the planet's most pressing problems as
mentioned we have one book out already
world-changing we have another book
coming out bright green which is a
world-changing guide to a future that
works both of these are really about
trying to tackle a fundamental set of
interlocking problems and luckily you
know this is a room full of people who
are really smart really well informed
and know those problems so I don't need
to say much about them but I will do a
short happy recap of the problems we
face this is fundamentally one of our
greatest challenges right it's the
future we live on a very very young
planet right and all of these people
have seen how you live and they're
interested in hearing more right if you
look at the developing world as a whole
right you'll see that younger people
make up the majority of its citizens and
that many people are just beginning to
enter their childbearing years their
years where they start to choose their
professions where they reach out for
more
fluence right on we are understanding
that there are some really bright trends
here right one of them is that we're
beginning to finally get that giving
women full access to their rights is in
fact one of the best investments we can
make and that women who have more
options who have more access to
education to their legal rights to
political rights to property rights two
jobs to healthcare choose pretty much
everywhere and in all situations to have
fewer kids and that is good news because
if we continue to give women their
rights make sure they have access to the
things that they deserve we could see
peak population in our lifetimes right
we hear a lot about population as a
driver of our problems but population is
actually a problem we can solve we know
the solution right and we know that in
fact we could see a peak and then a
gradual decline of population over the
next couple centuries this is not a
target that we have to ever chase a
receding goal on right we have the
ability to solve the population problem
and if we can solve for the prosperity
problem that comes with it we actually
have a good shot at solving the whole
thing but right now most people on the
planet are poor young and ambitious
right many live in conditions like these
but they aspire to conditions like these
right and pretty much everyone on the
planet knows how affluent Westerners
live right the most common shared
experience on the planet is having seen
Baywatch and so people have a sense of
what middle class or even upper class
life is and there's this vertical
emulation that's happening everywhere
around the world between at around
twenty fifty there's going to be
somewhere between four and six billion
people who have risen into the global
middle class right if they have anything
at all to say about it and the variation
has to do with population size and how
many disasters kind of occur between now
and then really and the choices that
those people make right the choices that
those billions of people make as they
rise into affluence right are going to
largely determine what happens on our
planet
right now the choices that are available
to them are twofold right they can
continue to be poor and frugal and they
know what that's like and they're not
that into it or they can be more like us
and be rich and wasteful right live
lives that have a lot of athletes meet
human needs very well but are also very
high impact ecologically what we don't
have yet is a third option right down
here in this corner the sustainable
development quadrant right you'll notice
that nobody's there except for that one
little dot which is Cuba and they're
lying so yeah you know really we don't
have an example of what this would look
like and we need one right because given
only those two choices young poor and
ambitious people are working overtime to
get their version of are wasteful wealth
right and this is a planetary disaster
in the making and it's happening really
quickly much more quickly than we here
in the US are used to thinking about as
a factor right um just as one little
data point last week tata motors
announced that in their first two weeks
of sales in india they sold 203,000
fully paid bookings right people walked
up with cash in hand and bought 203,000
automobiles in the first two weeks they
were available right this is a scale of
momentum that you know it's a woman its
SIA momentum that we run used to
thinking about and we need to really
provide a third choice they're right
between being poor and frugal and rich
and wasteful and we need to do it very
very quickly we need to do it very
quickly for another reason which is that
we need that third choice right right
now um we have based our wealth on doing
things which are incredibly
unsustainable and it's a completely fair
assessment situation to say that most of
the environmental problems especially
the big planetary problems that we face
now are our responsibilities right so
for example if you look at all of the
co2 emitted in the 20th century which is
what this map represents you'll see that
you know it's pretty hard to say that
Africans are to blame for the climate
problem since Canadians emitted as much
pollution as Africans did in the 20th
century you know we um
pretty much everybody in this room if
not everybody in this room has already
emitted more than a fair lifetime share
of co2 right we need to pull back from
that picture right the planet can't
survive with us being this wasteful and
in fact when you look at the mess that
we've left our you know our wealth looks
more and more like an intergenerational
Ponzi screen it's khiem right we have as
Paul Hawken said an economy where we
steal the future sell it in the present
and call it GDP and we know that things
are getting worse very very quickly
including my computer the Copenhagen
climate science congress their key
message number one worth knowing recent
observations confirm that given high
rates of observed emissions the
worst-case IPC scenario trajectories or
even worse are being realized and that
from observed events there is a
significant risk that many of the trends
will accelerate leading to an increasing
risk of abrupt or irreversible climate
shifts climatic shifts or as lord stern
put it the former chief economist of the
world bank or real radical he said this
is not a small possibility probability
of a rather unattractive outcome this is
a big probability of a very bad outcome
right we are beyond any debate as to
whether this is a problem and we're in
fact beyond any debate as to whether
this is an immediately pressing problem
we know that they're going to be huge
impacts very very soon and that some of
them have already begun Steven Chu
before he sort of got the memo that you
don't tell the press the truth proceeded
to say that there that we are looking at
a scenario where there's no more
agricultural in California he told the
LA Times right you know we know that
these things are rapidly degrading
global food crisis is likely to worsen
before it improves we have climate
change and energy crunch the UK
government's former chief scientist John
beddington said this is the perfect
storm right and we know everyone in this
room has you know has seen the PBS
specials read scientific papers whatever
and we all know that there's a whole
mess of trouble headed our way in
addition we're just beginning to get our
hands around the extent to which we have
undermined other aspects of our
planetary ecosystem right of the
biosphere
right we're beginning to understand that
the ecosystem services upon which we are
utterly dependent things like you know
pollination and pest control and so
forth are being eroded at an incredibly
rapid rapid rate the Deutsche Bank and
the European Commission did a study
finding that we have we are losing
natural capital right we're losing the
ability of those ecosystems to deliver
those services at a rate that if we had
to pay for it would be valued at between
two and five trillion dollars every year
right that's a that's a big deal and
we're starting to chip away at things we
never even thought were problems until
very recently like the ability of the
ocean to a creatures in the ocean to
calcify their shells right sounds like
something really obscure but basically
it's the it's the fundamental basis upon
which life on earth survives and we are
headed to a point where as Australia's
air sea center put it if co2 levels in
the atmosphere reach about 500 parts per
million we may well put Kal
calcification out of business in the
oceans right we may be on our way to
shutting down the oceans that's a pretty
big deal um and of course we're to
facing peak everything right name a
substance that comes out of the ground
and it's almost certainly running out
pretty much every mineral is has a has a
pretty dire timeline in terms of
availability of virgin supply we know
that energy except for coal which we
have way too much of is running short we
even know that we're running short on
top soil in many places right where
we're facing a world of severe shortages
and you know failing to address these
problems we know is an economy killer
right things that we've thought of as
externalities is things we don't have to
think about when we're thinking about
the economy are starting to become major
sources of business costs right as it's
been said our planet is becoming
uninsurable which is why the huge
reinsurance giants like Munich Re and
Swiss three and so forth are becoming
huge allies in the fight against climate
because they're realizing if this thing
really goes south they're in big trouble
they're out of business right and since
the costs of these things are also
rising right the costs of the damages
that we're doing but also the cost of
delay
we wait too long the needed transition
will in fact become financially
impossible right there's a point at
which we can't actually make the jump as
Paul Krugman said so can we afford to
save the planet yes we can now would be
a very good time to get started so um
that leaves us at this fundamental
situation which is that most poor people
do not have the resources or capacities
to both bootstrap themselves out of
poverty and simultaneously reinvent
prosperity right that is not to say that
there aren't billions of very smart you
know capable people who can you know
contribute to their own destiny and in
lots of different ways but let's face it
the you know the Yale's the Oxford's the
think tanks the you know policy houses
the big engineering companies right etc
etc etc these things are all in the
developed world pretty much you know the
vast majority of the world's capacity to
think about big systemic problems is in
the developed world we have it right and
we're also finding that we need to
reinvent ourselves right we have become
the brittle rich right we know that our
way of life while very affluent is
hanging by a thread right so really
fundamentally it's our job to reinvent
what rich means and it's their job to
get rich and that's kind of the deal we
need to strike here how do we do that
though how do we reinvent prosperity
well we need to basically start thinking
about a prosperity right that goes way
beyond anything that we have been
thinking about as sustainable up to this
point our debate about what's good
enough has become completely surreal in
light of known facts right what we need
to be thinking about is climate
neutrality we need to be thinking about
non-toxic ways of manufacturing and
producing goods and and doing
agriculture we need to be thinking about
closed-loop uses of resources and we
need to think be thinking about having
an economy that functions in terms of
ecological restoration rather than
drawdown of ecosystem services now all
this sounds really out there right
especially when you kind of go to DC and
you hear what people are talking about
they
you know but the reality is this is what
we need to do you know and the planet
isn't bargaining right the planet is not
going into closed sessions to bargain
with us right so we need to do this and
I actually think this is something we
can do and for the rest of my talk I'm
going to tell you about why I think this
is something we can achieve and we can
achieve quickly much of it we can do in
the next 20 years I think we can have
this model up and running in large parts
of the US in about 20 years I think that
in another 40 years we can have this
model spreading all around the world I
think that we can in fact invent a
prosperity which is both sustainable and
just which can be spread around the
world as well I think we can have a
future that's both bright and green and
the fundamental thing that we need to
understand about how we do that is that
in the 21st century using more does not
mean having more and using less does not
mean having less right we are so tied to
an industrial Arab model of thinking
about wealth right that we assume that
if you're using more stuff you must be
better off right and we also assume that
if anybody asks you to lose less stuff
right that they're trying to take
something away from you right but we
know already that there is not a direct
connection between the amount of stuff
in something and it's worth right so we
don't price oil paintings by the number
of tubes of oil it took to paint them
right you know we don't price patents by
the stock of the paper they're printed
on right we know it's the end value not
the volume of stuff and many kinds of
wealth we know can in fact grow
indefinitely even while their ecological
zero impact trends towards zero right
there are a whole lot of things that we
already know how to deliver with very
little ecological impact that increase
our wealth I'll tell you what won't save
us clean energy that's not to say the
clean energy isn't important we need
clean energy we need as much of it as we
can get but there is a very common idea
it's sort of usually the first step
after admitting the climate change
exists is to say great then we'll just
build a whole lot of windmills right and
the reality is if we don't dramatically
cut our energy use we can't keep up with
the amount of energy use the growth in
energy use that we're going to see
around the world and in fact salt
Griffith
a genius grant winner and and clean
energy pioneer believes that it's simply
beyond our physical capacities to
generate that amount of clean energy on
this planet right so we can't simply
grow our energy use and solve the
problem that way right in fact we're
probably going to need to think about
dramatically reducing our energy use in
order to bid it within the kind of
envelope that we can in fact provide
with clean energy and we're probably
looking at something more like a 2000
watt society a phrase worth googling in
your free time and we know that in fact
we can do this right many energy and
energy saving innovations already turn a
profit right this is a nother graph from
McKinsey again well known band of
radicals and but they're showing here
that uh you know many innovations save
energy in some cases large amounts of
energy and return a profit already under
current market conditions and if we add
a price to carbon as we increase the
price of carbon more and more things
will start to turn a profit right this
is why it's important to price carbon
right to implement a cap-and-trade
system or cap and dividend system our
carbon tax or whatever we could have
that argument for the rest of the day
but it's important to put a price on
carbon right so that we see an
acceleration of the deployment of
existing technologies and we can go a
long way on this but when you look at
the big picture and this is a chart from
WRI that's pretty cool you could look at
it pretty much all day at least if your
geek like me and you know it shows like
where all the different sources of
greenhouse gas come on what kind they
end up as and you know so forth and and
you figure out when you look at this
thing that we need to change you know
little things like how we build our
infrastructure and how we build
buildings and how we move people and
feed people and heat and cool air and
make things and ship things just little
things right it turns out that pretty
much every system upon which we depend
right needs fundamental reassessment you
know it's not enough to simply try and
swap out good pieces for bad pieces
right um there's this hope that we can
not change anything that will just get
really clever and we'll come up with a
bunch of little techno fixes and we'll
be able to swap out say hybrids for our
SUVs right clean
power for coal etc but that hope is not
going to be realized right we need a lot
more than swapping out the pieces we
need to change the system and not the
symptoms and this is doable one of the
biggest reasons this is doable is
because we're understanding now that
cities are absolutely the best fulcrum
point we have in fighting this battle
the most sustainable trip you will ever
take is the one you never take in the
first place because what you wanted is
right there right cities facilitate that
essential jump right they bring what we
otherwise would need to get through
access by driving into enough closeness
to us that we can get it by access by
proximity right if you live near the
things you want you drive less but it
also turns out that the more people you
bring into compact communities if
they're designed right and built well
right the more you actually start to see
all sorts of other benefits people start
to live well in smaller homes right huge
energy benefits there people start to
maximize the use of infrastructure right
running sewer lines 50 miles out into
the suburbs is not a very effective way
to provide people with infrastructure
right people start to have different
kinds of life choices it even minimizes
the amount of public space that's wasted
if you look on Google Maps or Google
Earth and you go look at like sort of
the worst suburb you can think of and
you actually like look at all the space
that's just wasted that's sitting there
is parking right you know we've built an
area of parking larger than the state of
Connecticut in the u.s. right we waste
vast amounts of space and all that space
wastage has huge implications which is
why the single strongest indicator of a
person's greenhouse gas emissions is the
community in which they live beats every
other every other factor and we know now
that people who live in sort of standard
sprawling suburban communities use many
times the energy of people who live in
high-density communities but we also
know that people who live in suburban
Green Communities right who have really
green mcmansions out on the fringe are
still using many times the the use of
people who are living in just sort of
standard urban communities
smart growth and compact development are
the closest thing we have to a simple
answer it's it's it's really that simple
if we have to stop now I just say okay
smart growth compact development go to
it luckily we don't have to start now
because there's a lot more stuff we know
how to build compact cities better right
we know how to make them extremely
livable right on there was a time where
the very idea of a city you know drew
scorn and and you know all sorts of bad
associations that time has passed in
fact the majority of Americans now say
that they want to live in what's called
walkable urbanism in the in the real
estate breakdown right they want to live
in walkable communities and this is
especially true for younger Americans
right people don't have to be sold on
the idea of living in combat communities
they want it and this is actually
reflected in real estate prices if you
look at where real estate prices took
the biggest dive during the bust it's
way out in sprawling communities if you
look at where they held their greatest
value it's in older compact communities
with with nice homes and we're getting
better at better figuring out how to fix
the gaps in combat communities how to
bring new ideas in so that we have
infill housing and adaptive reuse right
so we take what's there and make it good
this is just a really cool design I
think by daisuke and Jan for what you
could do with with gaps in between
buildings with new technologies right
and if you push the densities high
enough you start to get to what
vancouver calls eco density which is a
kind of high quality extremely compact
development that actually gets people
out of cars by improving their lives and
Vancouver has done what 20 years ago we
were told was impossible which is build
cities in such a way that you get North
Americans to stop driving right they've
done this in the last 20 years they've
actually managed to reduce the number of
vehicle miles traveled by the average
Vancouver aight i guess to you know
reduce the number of cars that are owned
to increase the amount of time that
people spend walking and reduce the
overall per capita energy use i mean
it's a pretty nice record of achievement
and you don't have to think that we're
going to end up in a bikers utopia to
realize that driving less makes you
money portland oregon right where
are you have very good combination of
planning of public transportation
especially light rail and lots and lots
of emphasis on biking and walkability
Portlanders save 2.6 billion dollars
every year that's about three percent of
the Portland regions annual economic
output in spending on cars and fuels
because they own fewer cars and drive
twenty percent fewer miles than other
residents alright that's just on cars
and fuel they're saving 2.6 billion
dollars a year through better planning
essentially right and that's just the
tip the iceberg because in fact cars
cost a lot more than just the fuel that
goes into them or the cost of buying it
in the first place right the
infrastructure is incredibly expensive
and there are all sorts of indirect
costs in terms of roads and healthcare
and pollution in fact the health care
costs alone of auto dependent suburbs
are really staggering there was a time
not that long ago when people associated
suburban living with health right well I
would live in the city except for that
I've got kids and I want them to be
healthy well it turns out that actually
living in the suburbs is a really good
way to predict early death there's first
of all the risk of car accidents which
is not minimal 42,000 Americans a year
get killed in car accidents the majority
of younger drivers who get killed in car
accidents live in the suburbs air
quality in outer ring suburbs is now
often worse than that in central cities
there's more lifestyle illness there's a
direct correlation between the amount of
time you spend in cars and the more you
weigh and the higher your blood pressure
is in fact Alan Durning of the sightline
Institute makes the argument that
walking or biking to work will actually
save you time even if it takes a few
more minutes because of the life you get
back the life expectancy you get back at
the end there's also of course social
social isolation which is something that
we're really beginning to understand has
a massive cost right that people
especially as they age the number of
friends and families and confidence that
they have is you know that's a pretty
good predictor of whether or not they're
going to stay healthy right so people
who are living in highly isolated places
are more at risk and there are several
studies that suggest that the additional
health costs of sprawl maybe as much as
twenty percent of the total health care
costs in the u.s. right the burden that
sprawl places on our health care system
may be
fifth of the total amount of money that
we're spending and it goes on from there
what about affordability one of the
arguments you are always hearing right
about sprawl is that well you know maybe
it's not ideal but we need this because
people need a cheap place to live right
we have even a phrase for it drive until
you qualify right but it turns out that
when you look at the numbers when you
add all the factors that go into
affordability which isn't just how much
your house costs it's how much it costs
to live there right how much do you
spend in transportation how much do you
spend another cost well when you add
those things together actually compact
community is far cheaper for most people
for most income levels and this is a
nice little engine you can use it's a
housing and transportation affordability
index you can do this where you live you
can try this at home and it will show
you basically that in where you live
although almost everywhere more compact
communities are more affordable and in
fact we're even learning how to
revitalize kinds of suburbs that have
been in long decline there's a whole
bunch of older post World War two
suburbs that we call the inner ring
right this is about whether it's where
52 million Americans live about a fifth
of all Americans live in these older
communities right there the community's
most of us drive through since they now
tend to be very working-class if not
actually poor but these are communities
that are right now having a very hard
time right they don't at the tax base to
solve their problems they've got aging
infrastructure aging housing stock right
this is the source of many of our future
problems right here but it turns out
that in fact there's a way to fix it
first way is that there's this
increasing force in many regional
politics about metropolitan coalition's
right central cities and entering
suburbs that band together to fight for
regional solutions that in fact benefit
more people right because right now the
game is rigged it's rigged in favor of
sprawl and outer ring suburbs so right
there there's an emerging political
force but we're also beginning to
understand that you can retrofit
entering suburbs if not my computer um
that you can up you know you can
actually bring the density of entering
suburbs up you can redo the
infrastructure there's all sorts of
great new solutions and when you get
density up just a little bit right just
about ten unit
per acre you know as the planners judge
these things most communities become
transit supportive that also means that
you get the ability to do some other
things like reconnect some streets and
revitalize the main street with some
local businesses right that bring a lot
of the kind of sustainability and
economic and health benefits of compact
communities back into these older
declining inner ring suburbs right we
know that we can actually save these
places we can make them better we can
bring them back to vitality right and
what we need to do that is not like
building giant skyscrapers in people's
backyards right this is transit
supported density right here this is a
fairly new development at the south end
of Seattle holly park well we don't have
the foggiest idea what to do is how to
fix sort of McMansion outer ring new
suburbs they're unsustainable now I at
least don't know of any they're already
an oversupply right we have more large
lot single-family homes than people want
truth and nobody has any idea how in any
kind of cost-effective way to turn these
things these communities into livable
communities and they're far too
expensive to bulldoze right so we just
don't know what to do right but there's
lots of it sitting out there rotting
right now and you know which is why i
think the bruce sterling is probably
right that if you are you know a young
creative adventuresome type the ruins of
this unsustainable or the 21st century's
frontier you know the the crazy gentrify
errs of the future are going to figure
out what to do with those um you know
all of this sometimes runs into a
barrier that we tend to think of cities
as being slow to change right we tend to
think of things like buildings and
neighborhoods things that they just
don't change very quickly right you know
sort of especially when you're
surrounded by buildings that are
hundreds of years old or whatever like
you tend to think you know hey this
stuff ain't going to go anywhere right
but the fact is that in the next 20
years because of the combination of
reasons population growth right driven
as much by immigration and longevity is
by new Earth's population shifts people
wanting to move in to livable
communities moving towards city's
changing where they live in terms of
moving towards the Sun Belt
the coasts and churn right just the
normal shifting of buildings remodeling
etc that we can expect to see by 2030
about half of all the buildings that
exist then we'll have been built or
substantially remodeled since 2010 right
we're basically about to like completely
redo most of the cities in the US and
the ones we don't redo are the ones that
are really kind of falling into weird
abandoned post-industrial situations
where there's even more need for change
right so cities are going to change fast
here and they're going to change even
faster around the world right most
people believe that the period of 20 25
to 2050 in the developing world will see
the largest increase in urbanization in
history in terms of the largest number
of structures built the largest number
of people moving to cities that will be
sort of peak cities and so this stuff's
going to change right and we know how to
do it better and we know how to add some
new stuff to it right one of the things
that we're gaining the ability to do is
to be a lot smarter about what we do and
we're beginning to be a smarter because
we can add intelligence and precision to
where things are and where we are I want
to give you an example of this it's my
friend's a Frank's project if the earth
were a sandwich and it's got an
important mission statement so I'll read
it never before have two pieces of bread
been simultaneously placed on the ground
directly opposite each other on the
globe thus making an earth sandwich the
fact that the earth has never been a
sandwich is probably why things are so
effed up now this is a really geeky
project this is about as geeky as it
gets what you have are two people on
opposite sides of the planet talking on
the cellphone looking at GPS coordinates
until they are exactly opposite one
another and then each takes a piece of
bread and puts it on the ground thus
making an earth sandwich right now you
might ask who the heck would want to go
to the trouble of making an earth
sandwich and it turns out actually a lot
of people want to make an earth sandwich
um in fact a really staggering number of
people have made the earth of sandwich
from pretty much every imaginable kind
of angle right people love doing this
and they love doing because there's this
new joy that people can find in being
connected around the planet being
connected to people you can't see
knowing where you are in relationship to
everything else and knowing where
everything else is right we're gaining
the ability to really see into things
right we're getting the ability to
measure things right and when you
measure them you use them differently
right so we found that when you move an
energy meter inside the house so you can
see it on a daily basis energy use drops
between seven and twelve percent right
but in any case really substantial
amount without doing anything else
simply because people see the money
turning up they see the energy ticking
off and they go you know I really don't
need to leave a light bulb burning in
the basement 24 hours a day right people
change immediately when you start to
measure things right um it's true in
lots of different ways there's the
so-called Prius effect that many of you
may have heard of which is when you take
two cars the exact same model same in
the body saving the engine same in every
way except for you put a mileage meter
in one car that car will get better
mileage than the other car why because
as anyone who's owned a hybrid or other
car that as a mileage meter will tell
you that car teaches you how to drive
better right you're striving down the
street in your like huh i'm only getting
20 miles per gallon instead of the 55
i'm supposed to get and then you say
well let's see if I accelerate a little
you know less rapidly from the green
light you know whatever and gradually
you see it start to tick up and it
basically trains you to become a less
wasteful driver right just by measuring
and of course we're getting better and
better at measuring more and more things
the grid itself that connects us in
terms of energy is getting smarter
Google which will one day on us all is
already on this right they have google
powermeter which pretty soon will be
available so that you can see what your
energy usage is you know on your iPhone
and see you know how much energy your
refrigerator is using or what your kids
are doing when you're away and you know
we're getting better and better and
better systems we're getting home energy
meters smart appliances smart grids
we're starting to get the ability to
hook distributed energy into the cyst
much more efficiently right and this is
especially true with things like energy
mortgages right we're a city covers your
costs for building like you know putting
a bunch of solar panels on your roof say
and you pay it back in your property
taxes but at a rate that's less than the
amount of money you're saving on your
energy bill right so you make money
every year the city gets more energy
supply in the city and helps meet its
needs while paying itself back right and
everyone sort of benefits right or with
net metering where utilities are
required to take back any extra energy
you generate any surplus energy right
you can help pay down the cost right so
sun's really going full blast you have a
bunch of solar panels there your your
energy meter will run in reverse all
right that's a pretty cool thing also
electric cars which are inherently more
efficient just mechanically they're
about four times more efficient than an
internal combustion engine they're also
really jet Sounion if they're like this
I really love this this is a you know
the apt era which is only for sale in
California yet but as soon as it's for
sale in Washington I planned on one and
you know the big problem with electric
cars has always been the range right
that you can't really the batteries
aren't good enough you can't carry
enough batteries to like drive across
the country in one well che Agassi said
what if we came up with a different
model right which is essentially gas
stations for electric cars it's called
Project better place and it has places
you can pull up in charge if that's what
you want to do but if you have the right
model of car with the right kind of
battery you can also drive up and just
swap the batteries out right so you take
full batteries give them your empties
and drive on right and this is actually
going into deployment now in California
they're building several billion dollars
worth of trials in the Bay Area to do
this so this is you know infrastructure
that's readily available and when you
put all this stuff together it starts to
behave in really unexpected ways um for
one thing cars with batteries in them
our energy sponges all right they sit
there most of the time like 23 hours a
day just you know making sure they're
totally topped off with energy right and
so when you're not using it it's a
potential power supply right and one of
the biggest problems we have or a big
problem we have with our electrical grid
are these Peaks urges right there are
times you know heatwave you know people
get home from work what have you we're
suddenly for a couple hours or even just
a day there'll be a massive demand on
energy and we have whole power plants
around the country that exists simply to
meet that peak demand when needed right
whole coal plants if you can shave off
that peak demand that's a little chart
up there which is very legible but if
you can shave that off right if you can
reduce that peak demand in fact greatly
reduce the amount of energy that we need
to spend to provide energy for everybody
right this also has another benefit
though right if you have energy sponges
sitting around that know they're really
smart they know when energy is cheap
they know when they're going to be used
etc etc you can program them you know to
always be full at you know 9am when
you're going to drive to work whatever
right it also makes the problem of
intermittency that we've heard about
with with clean energy go away because
right now you know we only have power
when the wind blows for wind power we
only have power when the Sun shines for
solar power etc right you know when
there's high tides tidal power works
better right now if there's extra energy
and people don't need it it just goes to
waste right and then when we do need it
and it's not there it's a problem but if
you have a system of millions of
batteries connected to one another right
and millions of appliances that are
smart and know when to charge up if
their batteries or when to go into
action if they're you know if they are
appliances as soon as we get big surges
of clean energy we can use that and
harness it right and when the energy
dips off we have reserved we've already
taken care of a lot of our business it's
a very very good trade-off and luckily
there are billions of dollars in the
stimulus bill I think 10 billion to
study this so there's some good stuff
happening um there's also another
benefit which I could go off on for a
while because I've been writing a lot
about it recently but I'm not going to i
must bear you this smart grids like a
lot of sustainability innovations also
make us more resilient it's something we
don't talk very much about because it's
kind of not very good dinner
conversation but you know our current
society is really brittle right there
are lots of ways to break it right we
can break it unintentionally all
time right a you know power blackouts a
cheap little part in some you know power
line in the Midwest Goes Down and
suddenly everyone in New York has no
power right terrorist attacks you know
public health problems weather disasters
what have you right there's lots and
lots of potential problems out there
that can make our lives miserable if we
rely on a few you know concentrated
hierarchical centralized systems to run
everything we are incredibly vulnerable
to disruptions of those systems the more
that we were able to bring distributed
parts together in an intelligent way the
safer we get it's a benefit that's worth
remembering um but when you start to
make things smarter you also get other
benefits you get these walk shed
technology benefits you get to start to
think about what's near you and how to
get there this is google walking maps
which is still a little rough when I ran
it to get from my neighborhood down here
in the neighborhood of columbia city in
seattle to downtown seattle it first
told me to take i-5 so still you know
still working out the kinks but you get
the idea it's going to be easier and
easier and in fact a better example is
ride the city which uses a better data
some user generated data and some other
stuff to figure out what the best bike
routes are it's not available where I
live yet but it's an example of the kind
of thing that gets easier and easier
right you start to get more and more
ability to get around the way you want
to get around in fact you even get the
ability to start using a public
transportation better these are two of
my favorite iPhone applications one is
one bus away which will tell you at
least in Seattle when your bus is going
to be at your bus station right you're
at your bus stop so you don't need to go
down there and wait for an extra 15
minutes because it's late it will tell
you hey that bus is already running nine
minutes late so you know you can go down
there on time and just get on board you
don't have to wait in the rain very good
in Seattle the second one is even cooler
which is I nap which is an application
that as you get to the stop before your
stop or other pre-programmed
destinations it will set off the alarm
in your phone and wake you up
another part of this is that these
solutions start to loop right a lot of
things are only garbage when the person
who wants them can't find them right you
know when you add innovative services to
this stuff right to living close
together and having lots of intelligence
but what's going on you get the ability
to do new things this is a screen
capture from the site garbage scout
which will tell you that there's a pair
of used underpants on Bedford Avenue in
Brooklyn left a mere 15 hours before
this business model has not turned out
necessarily to be the success they hoped
but nonetheless there are lots of really
great things to do and you know one of
them is that when you know where things
are and who has them it gets easier to
share them who here is familiar with car
sharing okay so I don't need to go too
far into it i'll just say that uh you
know one of the really great things
about it is that just you know like a
decade ago you had to be a real crunchy
chewy hippie to want a car share right
because you had to fill out a form and
send it in by mail and like you know be
like i'd like to use the car on saturday
at moon unit doesn't need it you know i
mean it was really not very easy right
now you know you can walk down the
street flip up in your cell phone open a
browser make a reservation walk up to
the nearest car that you've just
reserved use your swipe card get in and
drive away it doesn't get much more
convenient than that back in many
neighborhoods it's a lot more convenient
than owning your own car and as it turns
out people who share cars get rid of
their cars in London they found that
it's about six to one every time there's
a new car share car about six people get
rid of a car other studies in more in
denser urban environments and especially
in more American context have found that
it may be as many as 20 21 right that
there may be as many as 20 people who
get rid of a car every time a car is
made available to share right now the
thing that we often forget about cars is
that a huge portion of the ecological
burden of the car has nothing to do with
driving it right it's the energy it took
to make the car it's the engine eat and
energy it took to deliver the car to you
just sell it at the dealership to
maintain it right to have a parking
space for it right 20 parking spaces
take a lot of energy and a lot of
materials it's the energy it takes
to get rid of it when it's done etc i
mean i could go on on there's lots of
hidden costs and owning a car when you
share that car you share those costs we
don't tend to think of it that way but
when you if a car has X amount of impact
and 20 people share it rather than
having 20 cars you don't get 20 x impact
right you get x / 20 impact right you
actually get a much reduced impact right
I'm that didn't quite work math there
but you know what I mean um yeah I knew
I should have stayed in school um anyway
lots of things can be shared right uh
piecing is one of my favorites it's in
Barcelona it's it's a bike sharing
program and if you are a citizen of
Barcelona you can join this thing for
like 25 euros or 24 euros and and you
can take any bike from any of these
smart bike racks anywhere in the city
you use swipe card it'll give you a bike
you pull it out you can ride it to any
other bike rack right and push it back
in if your trip is half an hour or less
it's totally free if it's more than half
an hour there's a charge that sort of
racks up as you go um it's incredibly
popular right it started with a hundred
bikes at 14 stations and in a year and a
half it grew to six thousand bikes at
four hundred stations and they're
expanding it from there right incredibly
popular everyone loves it you see like
you know little punk hipsters riding
these bikes and you see old grandmas
writing these bikes you know and you
know one of the there there are some
problems with it um they found for
example that people like to ride the
bikes downhill so they ended up needing
to buy a fleet of trucks to take bikes
back up to the highest hills you know
but by and large it works beautifully
right and it makes access to other modes
of transit really easy right it makes it
means you can jump off a train in
Barcelona and if there's a bee singh
stationed there you can just jump right
on a bike and ride to where you want to
go where there's another be Singh
station jump off and you're there right
I mean there's no muss no fuss you don't
have to take your bike on subway etc and
lots of things can be shared who he runs
a power drill okay about about normal
well the average power drill gets used
for between six and twenty minutes in
its entire lifetime
I know that mine hasn't been used much
and we've made millions of power drills
and backed up in assured we've made on
the planet hundreds of millions of power
drills and what we want is really not
the drill right I'll make myself the
test case we're here right um I bought a
drill because I had some paintings I
wanted to hang and I needed to make a
hole in the wall so I could sink a thing
in there to hang the thing off right you
can tell I'm really handy right uh and
you know but so I needed a drill just to
make some holes basically and now that
drill is going to sit in my basement
holding down a shelf like you know for
the rest of my life probably right
that's not a good ecological bargain
right especially when there are lots of
other ways to get the hole in your wall
right there are lots of people there are
tools sharing libraries right can be in
community centers and libraries there to
sharing services there are people now
who you can order the tool they'll bring
it by your house drop it off and come
pick it up and it's still a small
fraction of the cost of buying your own
right not to mention that you then are
sharing that powered tool with however
many other people and thus sharing the
ecological costs right and this stuff
doesn't have to be low status right it
doesn't have to be boring things there's
a company in Seattle called bag borrow
or steal that basically is a sharing
service for high-end jewelry accessories
this kind of stuff right so if you have
an event that you want to go to that
might you know be a great opportunity to
show off a five-thousand-dollar handbag
right and you don't necessarily want to
buy one yourself for the one use well
these are your people you know they will
give it to you you can bring it to the
thing have a good time bring it back and
the next person can use it later right
there are already lots of high status
things that we share on a regular basis
that we don't tend to think of as shared
services right things like health clubs
country clubs right what's a country
club it's a shared golf course right
elite universities right what are elite
universities they are shared faculties
right be very expensive if everybody had
to buy their own faculty right so you
know we have more and more of these ways
of thinking about things in new ways but
still right now almost everything we
make is
destined to become trash or pollution
right you know almost every even in a
really awesome building like this much
of the thing most of the things in this
room are probably destined to end up in
a landfill right they're probably
already in the landfill in effect they
just don't know it yet right and it is
possible to change that though right
because the same kind of forces that
make it possible to share things make it
possible to renegotiate the bargain
between producers and users right to
change what it means to be a user of
something um you know that little white
airplane pillow that you get when you
take a flight we don't think of that
airplane pillow the same way that we
think of the pillow that our grandmother
embroidered right we think of it in a
different way it's a use object right
nobody like gets choked up and when they
leave the white airplane pillow on the
thing go what will I ever do right you
know you don't have a remote an
emotional relationship to your airplane
pillow right why should you have an
emotional relationship to your
refrigerator right you shouldn't write
these are things that are potentially
services when we're done with them
somebody ought to take them back when
there's a better version somebody ought
to come replace it right and we know how
to do this right we know that if you
have responsibility for producers to
take back the objects they make the
design of those objects themselves
changes and the experience of using them
improves we need a real revolution in
the basic chemistry and design of most
of the things that we use right most of
them are made without the Vegas thought
of them ever being recycled or in any
way turned into anything other than
garbage right i mean i have this cell
phone here which you know motorola made
and basically you know the only options
for this phone are essentially when i
drop it in the recycle box at like the
phone store it it probably is just going
to get ground up and made into like a
bench or something it might get sent to
china where kids will pick it apart for
the valuable metals inside using blow
torches and no masks that's about the
best you could hope for I mean that's
not a very good outcome and you know and
frankly most of these phones are really
there so I recommend to you going at
some point if you can there's a there's
a nokia site about their visa
clean plan and it's really hard to tell
because they're finished whether it's
serious or not um it could be a satire
it's really hard to tell but they
basically you know they announced their
their their recycling plan and it
basically involves like a series of
ladies ripping the cover off something
and dropping it into a grinder right I
mean there really is very little
recycling that's possible with these but
if Motorola got this phone back when I
was done with it if they had millions
and millions of phones headed back their
way that they were responsible for
getting rid of in a responder you know
an ecologically responsible and
economically productive way they would
design the phone different they would
design a phone like this one this phone
will pop apart when exposed to high heat
right the adhesives will come unstuck
the screws have memory metals in them
that will unthread themselves the whole
thing pops part easily can be all the
pieces can be tossed into the various
bins recycled reused what what have you
right this is the kind of phone you make
when the phone is coming back to you and
it turns out that all sorts of
innovations become profitable right
because of improved life cycles of
energy use of material use when you have
to take the thing back right so here's a
chair that's cradle to cradle all these
parts are non-toxic can be recycled etc
you know their carpets you give back
like interface floor there's office
furniture you recycle even office paper
can become a service instead of a thing
right there's local paper for London
which is basically everyone who you know
in a building who puts their you know
their recycled office paper into bins it
gets taken off gets recycled and they
bring that paper back as we cycled paper
right you get your same you know you can
not read next week's memo on last week's
memo you know it's pretty useful and
imagine moving towards a world where
that kind of thing was absolutely the
norm all right where everything in our
life moved endlessly through these loops
and we're as easy for us to be a part of
that that's the world we're moving
towards right we're moving towards a
world where you will not own a garbage
can because there's no a way to throw
things right we're moving towards a
zero-waste world with no landfills right
we're moving to a world where everything
when you get rid of it you loop it back
you know this is this is not only
possible this is stuff that people are
doing
when you start to think about flows
right you start to actually get all
sorts of abilities right you start to
getting the ability to work with nature
instead of against it we spent enormous
amounts of time energy and money
fighting natural forces that have been
understood for thousands of years like
the fact that if you have a window that
faces south you gain heat right um we're
getting better and better at this stuff
though bill dunster over in the UK is
building zero energy homes in the north
of England largely using sort of passive
design and you know he as he puts it the
north of England is one of the few parts
of the inhabited world with less
sunshine than Seattle so if it can be
done there it can be done anywhere and
we know that this stuff can even be done
at scale right this is bianca ingles
mountain in Copenhagen a passive solar
almost zero energy building that's high
density we know that we can do the stuff
really nicely in large numbers we also
know that we can start to tap other
kinds of flows right right now we treat
rainwater as pollution water falls from
the sky it's pure and then we spend
billions and billions of dollars to
build storm sewers to cart it away from
our houses where most of the time
especially in heavy rains it mixes with
human waste and gets dumped into the
nearest body of water right we spend an
enormous amount of money polluting
rainwater right that's not a very
sensible way of going about things and
we fact already have many many better
options right we know how to harvest
rainwater we know how to use rainwater
in our gardens we know how to use
rainwater as gray water for things like
toilet tanks and such I mean you guys
know but we're getting even better than
that right we're starting to get the
ability to actually wire things together
and and respond to flows you know City
of Seattle is working on a system that
will wire together cisterns right so
they'll collect rainwater but as a big
storm is coming they'll all release the
rain water slowly before the storm gets
there so that you'll have a huge sponge
ready to soak up all that new rainwater
and you don't get the kind of combined
sewer overflows that they're called when
you have a lot of storm water washing
through the system minimizing flooding
and that kind of thing we could already
using technology we have right now
recycle much of our water right we could
really reinvent the whole urban
hydrology and I encourage you to keep an
eye on Australia here they're really the
ones who are going hog-wild with this
stuff turns out that being in like
you're 50
teen of a drought kind of changes your
relationship to water you know and while
vertical farms which you may have heard
of don't make sense they will never
pencil in terms of their energy use lots
of interesting building retrofits do
make sense this is the flower box
building and what they did I don't know
if you can see it very well but what
they did is they took flower boxes and
mounted them on the exterior of the
building giving shading during the
summer for those windows but also giving
area that the people above can grow
things in kind of cool little innovative
solution there's lots of urban
agricultural innovation this stuff is
really well known and you know if you're
feeling like you're not up to speed on
what can be done with with agriculture I
recommend you know going to watch the
latest Michael Pollan talk he's pretty
awesome with all that stuff and you know
so basically it comes down to really
using the flows right we ought to be
using the sunlight right we ought to be
using every surface whether it's you
know plants or solar panels or windows
or are we ought to be making all those
surfaces work with the Sun we ought to
be using every drop of water right we
ought to be using the wind when it blows
right as it stands now most of the time
we fight these things right we spend a
lot of energy to not do that and we I
think also to be thinking of this in
ways that are both poetic and practical
um this is one of my favorite designs
it's for lunar resonance street lights
as the moon gets brighter it in fact
gets brighter than the streetlights if
it's a full moon on a clear night and so
why don't the streetlights just turn off
this just as a simple switch that will
measure the amount of moonlight falling
and dim or brighten the streetlights as
needed right so that on really bright
clear night with the moonlight out you
could walk through the streets and you
know be surrounded by moonlight rather
than energy use all of this stuff also
conspires towards transparency and I
would actually say that this is one of
the largest forces that is poorly
understood in the environmental
community right at the moment we are
getting better and better ability to
tell the backstory of stuff right we're
used to thinking of the story of things
right um you know if i use a mac you
know the story i'm trying to tell you is
that I'm creative right you know if i
use a motorola you know
the story I'm trying to tell you is I
didn't shop very well for my cell phone
um and uh you know but we aren't used to
thinking about the backstory right where
did this machine come from where did the
materials in a come from who made it
under what conditions how did it get to
me how much energy was used in that how
much energy will be used that I don't
notice while i'm using it right where
will it go when i'm done right all those
things with a back story and if the 20th
century was all about selling you the
story increasingly the 21st century is
all about telling you the back story
right and in many cases right there are
simple and true back stories behind
objects that are great marketing
material right so this is the wrapper
for a green and blacks chocolate bar
telling you basically where it came from
what's in it and where it's going cuz
pretty simple straightforward good
backstory right this is good stuff that
came from nice people and you're doing a
good thing by eating it but you know
there are also um there are also many
cases in which the backstory is not so
kind right one of these is virtual water
who here is familiar with the concept of
virtual water okay bunch of Smarties I
didn't even know this thing a lot of
like a year ago I'd never heard of it um
but uh basically you know much of the
harm that we do happens outside of our
direct usage right so there's energy
embedded in this you know laptop we
never see the energy used it was used
when it was made it right when is made
we don't see that there's also water
embedded in almost everything right it
takes my water to grow things takes
water to mine things takes water to
manufacture them right so in effect
there's water embedded in this laptop as
well but we don't see it right now there
are great many things that get sent from
the driest poorest parts of the world to
the wettest richest parts of the world
that have huge amounts of water embedded
in them right so for example a steak
from argentina won 300 gram steak takes
45 hundred liters of water to produce
before it comes to us we never get you
know pallets of 4,500 liters of water
delivered along with the steak so we
tend not to think about it right but if
in fact this stuff is revealed you start
to realize that there's all sorts of
things that were involved with that
aren't very savory right that are that
are really wasteful
not that good and we're gaining more and
more ability to figure this stuff out on
the fly it's already true that if you
have a cell phone you can take a picture
and send it to one of various sites i
like wats on its site started again by
cell griffith and you know find out
what's behind that product right it'll
tell you you know the refrigerator will
tell you the consumption packs it'll
tell you what metals are in it how much
energy use is made increasingly there
are sites that will even tell you the
labor backstory of things right so this
was made in that plant in China which
has a bad record for human rights right
we're gaining the ability to figure out
more and more like what was actually
what actually happened in this screen
like not screens in general but in well
apparently not an on screen either but
you know what happened in a specific
object you know and we're gaining the
ability to test those assumptions also
against global standards like the ami
standard right so you know that if that
that what people are telling you and
sort of this crowd sourcing way is
actually you can judge it against sort
of more absolute well-known standards
and all this is giving us more and more
inclination to judge what's good and bad
on this is a photo from the site Fu H
tube a very popular site that is all
about pictures of people flipping off
Hummers thousands of people flipping off
Hummers and the reason why beyond the
fact that it's kind of cute the reason
why this is important is because more
and more and more it is socially
acceptable and it is indeed ethically
imperative many people believe to call
oneself and others out on wasteful
destructive behavior and this is just
going to accelerate because we've just
seen the tip of the iceberg about how
transparent things are about to get
right there is as technology spreads as
social practices spread right we gain
more and more ability to see behind the
curtain right so when Tony Blair and his
last election said no press interviews
I'm going to go talk to the people right
The Guardian said well screw that if you
see Tony Blair take a picture if you
hear him record him right um if you know
where he is send an email it was the
Blair watch project
right and they basically got constant
coverage of Tony Blair for that entire
campaign right this is pretty easy to do
another site that I would commend to
your attention is X on secrets or the
next time you hear some blowhard telling
you the climate change isn't real go
find out how Exxon paid them and this
site will pretty much tell you there are
a handful of independent blowhards but
most of them are on the payroll and you
know it is increasingly possible to pull
back the curtain on almost anything and
this is something that is really worth
noting and William Gibson the science
fiction writer futurist puts it this way
and I think it's worth thinking about
that it is becoming unprecedented Lee
difficult for anyone anyone at all to
keep a secret in the age of the leak and
of the blog of evidence extraction and
Link discovery truths will either out or
be outed later if not sooner this is
something I would bring to the attention
of every diplomat politician and
corporate leader the future eventually
we'll find you out the future will have
its way with you in the end you will be
seen to have done that which you did
you'll be seen to have done that what
you did for much of human history people
have relied on not being seen to not
that which they actually did that's
changing and it's changing quickly and
it's changing like people who are
putting their lives on the line to do it
and it's changing by people who are
getting really creative right about
showing people what this stuff means
future sea-level rise bunch of art
students in San Francisco ran around San
Francisco and said if the sea rises you
know three meters here's where it's
going to be and basically showed
everyone what's going to be under water
if you know we lose part of Greenland or
ebon in Hanson's maj bear which shone a
laser of shined whatever I don't know
what the English is for that I only work
with words anyway this is a coal coal
fired power plant every time it goes on
the laser goes on and shines up the
stuff that's coming out so people can
see in real time you know the emissions
that are happening there or you know the
Dutch is always masters of
understatement if the water reached this
level we would not need the bridge drive
on maybe we will achieve this
you know and we're seeing lots and lots
of ways for people to tell new stories
for people to connect this is the
community wiki in the neighborhood that
I live in and this is something that
could not have existed 10 years ago
right and it's incredibly useful and
powerful I mean not only does it tell
you like when there's a sale at the
store or like what the movie is at the
local revival theater or whatever but
also people are on here talking about
land use decisions talking about you
know obscure like public input sessions
that the city's having and stuff and
people get mobilized to this right my
neighbors including people who have
probably never been to a public hearing
in their lives are starting to do things
like send comments on e is you know like
really get involved in the system it is
possible to do it and it's possible to
do it cheaply this is run in somebody's
spare time with no money right this
stuff is taking off and I could give you
a thousand examples of this right we saw
tons of them in the last presidential
election right we're seeing tons and
tons more but the fact basically remains
the same that there are lots of ways to
do this right and we have a lot of
untapped energy this is clay sure keys
you know a calculation which is that it
takes a hundred million mental hours to
build a Wikipedia right so if that's a
wikipedias worth of attention that's
five days of the amount of time that
people spend playing World of Warcraft
right we have plenty of extra attention
cycles and plenty of people who are
looking to get involved and this stuff
is just going to take off there's one
piece of this though that I think is
really something that we all need to
think more about that we haven't got the
answers to and that's really
fundamentally about our happiness right
we know that the answer is to make
better cities that use better systems
tell better stories right that's as
close to a formula of sustainable
prosperity's we have but we also need to
recover our understanding of something
else which is what makes us happy we
have gone a little astray here I
remember when a flat-screen TV was a
pretty cool thing to have right now you
really kind of have to have
home theater I remember when somebody
who flew in first class was really you
know they they were pretty much making
it now you pretty much have to have a
private jet right if you're anyone and
really if you're anyone you have a
flying private home theater no joke and
you know more and more we have been
dumbed down by the stuff we have right
we've been marketed to and brand it and
you know sort of spun in every possible
direction till we've forgotten the
relationship between prosperity and
enjoyment right we are much wealthier
than we were 30 years ago but we're also
demonstrable s happy right people know
fewer people right they report that they
have fewer people they could tell a
major issue to the fact I was just
hearing on the radio that it's something
like one-fifth of all Americans don't
feel they have anyone they could tell a
major crisis to like that's that's
pretty pretty awful right um we have
more lifestyle stress than we had right
we have higher levels of depression
right we have more and more people
responding that they think the best days
of their nation of their community or of
their family are behind them right that
the future is going to be grimmer right
we're destroying the earth to get the
prosperity we have and that's the result
we have right I mean Homer Simpson could
do better right we need to reclaim a
different understanding of things right
we know what makes us happy and it
certainly does involve a certain degree
of material prosperity and security but
it also really is much more about the
experiences we have the relationships we
have the quality of the lives we have
the degree to which we feel there's
meaning in our work you know and if we
try simply for ourselves and simply
ingredi materialistic ways right rather
than in smart materialistic ways those
tribes are going to turn to dust in our
hands you know I would argue that they
already are I'd argue that it's pretty
easy sell to say that America is in some
serious decline right now and that this
is the primary cause of it all right um
but that's not our only choice we could
do better we can do different right we
could in fact decide that we're going to
change what it
needs to be wealthy improve our the
quality of our lives live happier lives
right and leave a legacy of having saved
the earth that seems to me to be a
pretty good bargain you know a much
better bargain to make and you know we
aren't going to make that bargain unless
lots of people get out there and start
you know saying the emperor has no
clothes on and we can do better so you
know I'll just leave you with the
thought that as Paul Hawken said you are
brilliant and the earth is hiring you
know and ask you to keep up the good
work thank you very much
well thank you Alec that's a very
provocative and exciting look at about a
potential future for all of us he's
agreed to stay with for a few minutes
and I think we have about maybe five to
ten minutes of that we can use to ask
questions so are there any good
questions out there yes sir the
refrigerator I'm either your best friend
of your worst enemy i'm an unrepentant
libertarian i made the mistake of
falling in love with an FES graduate so
or I by the vision okay but my concern
is the contrast between the state ism
that some people believe is implied by
this kind of vision at liberty and
freedom and and so you really didn't
speak to that dimension in the nature of
the solutions can we achieve this and
still honor the notion of freedom and
liberty that is inherent in the way we
live our lives now well I certainly
think so on I mean I think that most of
the fundamental liberties we have our if
anything improved by a sustainable
future I think that if you're talking
about material choices I think we can
totally honor them because I think the
best way to do it is essentially make
people pay the true cost of what they're
doing right i mean you know my right to
swing my face stands at your nose right
my lip right to pollute right ends at
the melting of somebody else's glacier
right and you know I think that if we
make people if we simply rig the system
towards fairness right make people pay
the true cost of things that we will in
fact find that most people will make
that choice in fact I think the vast
majority people will already make the
choice they just don't have the
opportunity you know we're seeing right
now for example in livable communities
like people wanting there's much more
demand for housing in walkable livable
communities than there is out on the
French right that's already a market
ship that the market hasn't caught up to
you know so I do think that it's
entirely possible to do this without
command and control dictates I don't
want anyone telling me what my
refrigerator should look like either
right you know but I do think that
somebody telling me that I'm going to
have to pay a lot more for energy or
that I'm gonna have to pay the true cost
of throwing that refrigerator away if i
buy one that can't
recycle I think that's completely fair
some great okay I want to really thank
you for coming yeah it's had a brief
question i think the i'm a student here
at the environments school in the school
of management the woman before me
actually addressed my concern but you're
mentioning about the housing in the
affordable housing and i believe in the
vision one hundred percent but my
parents are actually have spent their
lives trying for the McMansion appeal
living out in the country we're also
from California so I think there's a lot
of people that you know they say
neighbors sue each other a little bad
neighbors make noise they but they want
that ideal and I feel really bad coming
to them my parents in criticizing them
to paraphrase if they're capitalistic
materialism and consumption so do you
have any thoughts on the process of
these people that have the means or at
least think they have the means to live
this lifestyle and it's a psychological
difference between the old and the young
and do you see any trends there yeah
well I mean I I that's 18 questions in
one and i'll do my best to answer it
quickly and one answer i guess you know
i think that there is a very jarring
cultural shift that's going to happen um
there is really no way to make a certain
lifestyle which for certain people is
the very definition of affluence
sustainable there's no way to make you
know a five-acre lot McMansions with
people driving to work and you know
highly dependent on extended supply
lines you can't make that sustainable
it's just not going to happen and so at
a certain point that argues that it's
going to need to stop and you know i
have real hopes that we'll find
something that's very cool that will
replace it you know but i don't know
what that is yet and i think that you
know we can and should be very sensitive
to the human cost of those things you
know we can acknowledge that people you
know have made choices for entirely
rational and good reasons in their minds
that now have negative costs right but i
think at the same time we shouldn't say
that okay just because this is your
dream home you know that you should get
a tax break on your gas or something
right I don't think we need to cater to
people who have made those decisions I
think if we in fact start to do true
cost pricing and how the responsible
fair tax policies and stuff like that
you're going to see those people
choosing those homes and many fewer
numbers all right but I do think that
there's no way to avoid that there's
going to be a political conflict here in
fact I would say that the conflict
between people who are living in the
favorite quarter as the planners call it
a sort of exurban suburbs who tend to
drive more tend to listen or talk radio
but heavily Republican you know etc are
you know the difference between those
people and the people who are doing
metropolitan politics sort of working
class and ring people and people who are
struggling for livability and central
cities that that is more or less the
politics we have you know when you look
at sort of the purple nation maps from
any of the recent elections what you'll
see is is basically you know people who
live in the inner ring and people who
live on this you know in central cities
a vote against people who live on
suburban fringe and you know I think
that that conflict is not going to go
away I don't think there's any way it
can go away I think it's going to be a
conflict that defines our politics for a
while hopefully we'll get past it but I
also do think that there's a huge
generational issue here I mean you know
if you are under 30 now you're quite
likely to see you know the you know the
compost hit the fan here these are
decisions that are going to make you
know that are going to be with you for
the rest of your life and there is you
know a real difference between how this
how these set of issues look to somebody
who's say 21 and how they look to
somebody who's 75 we see that in polls
but we also see it in politics right we
see people who see this as realistic
practical immediate to do and people who
see this as you know nice day dreaming
from the young kids who would like to
save the world that's a political divide
that's a culture gap that's a generation
gap and I think how that plays out is
kind of the story anyway thank you very
much
you
you